welcome everyone to another reddit video
last week I titled the video pure
coincidence thinks I hate it it was a
bunch of weather it doesn't matter
what's important is as it turns out
there is already a reddit called things
I hate it so now we can go through
things that we can go afterwards safe
thanks I hate it let's just jump into it
thanks I hate it cookies with Vicks it's
an elite combo wait yeah what is that I
don't understand
thanks I hate this mean I don't get it
what is it what vapor rub thanks I hate
custom face printed helmet hate the look
of a helmet but still want to be safe
for a limited time you can have your
whole head printed call now thanks who
wouldn't want to have that that's
amazing that's great thanks I love it
that's awesome I've been telling my
white friend he looks like Woody from
Toy Story he sends me this picture
randomly Thanks
I hate woody now Jesus Christ excuse me
this offensive not all when people look
like woody okay thanks I hate Balu why
would you do that
cool thanks I get it Mary it's not
Thanks it's thanks I hate Donald Duck
don't get in Mickey I'm naked what
difference does it make you never wear
pants right I never thought about that
of course Thanks it's not rewarding at
all I thought it would be funny I'm just
annoyed if you're a junior
your mom has probably moaned your name
Jerome well thank God that's the worst
thing I've ever heard
Thanks I hate Will Smith as Jeannie well
yes
thanks the genie is ruined I hate
everything about this especially the
hands a fun April Fool's Day surprise
replace the cream in Oreo cookie with
yourself to give your friend a
fun-filled cream surprise that they will
struggle to forget until the day they
die April Fool's
I am the cream
the hands why would you draw hands like
that what would you do I would you to
their Thanks
I hate Oreos now yeah thanks I hate
laughing now I don't like anything
anymore
I think we should just go through
everything in life just ruin everything
and then you can never be disappointed
anymore it actually makes a lot of sense
Thanks I hate the Loch Ness monster
how did I like it now I don't know it's
it makes sense because he's tap dancing
and that's what everyone does in
Scotland right thanks I hate mermaids
now oh god don't ruin mermaids please do
not ruin mermaids for me do you sleep
No let me sleep now do you know that
mermaids in cartoon uses starfish as a
bra starfish has their mouth in the
center of their underside mermaids only
use starfish to get their nipples I love
it
don't tell me Ariel has the starfish
don't tell me o star Arielle thanks I
hate Thomas the chain
Oh God not Thomas the child don't ruin
Thomas the child but the scariest thing
I've ever seen in my life what in the
world what were they thinking when they
did Thomas the Tank Engine I don't
understand why on God's earth would you
put a face on a train like that I don't
understand and I will never understand
Thomas the Tank Engine needs to die I
don't ever want to see it again it's
already ruined trained for me thanks I
hate trains now
thanks I hate it stop sending me this
thanks because I already don't mind okay
I don't care
Thanks I hate popsicles now now y'all
ride popsicles what have they done
Edward
sticking Bella's menstrual cup in the
freezer yummy popsicles thanks my first
attempt I'm creepypasta beginning here
go
on me carpeted kitchen does that exist
I'm not here in UK they want to put
carpets everywhere I don't know why
can we put a carpet day that's great but
can we put a coffee they that's what
they say that's literally all British
conversations here
thanks I hate horses yes of course hey
it looks like the top of the Tank Engine
SWAT why of course I draw horses all the
time I know what it look like
they have the nose on the side and the
big giant eyes the deadpan expression of
course oh thanks I hate it this is not
the right one you know that mean that
really old mean I'll just have to do
this I just have to do this and you will
understand and if you don't understand
then trust me it's better for everyone
what is this depravity each morning I
put one uncooked ravioli in a thermos I
pour hot water over it steeping it like
tea and then I drink it all day at work
I work at the White House and at the end
of the day as I take the last sip of the
tea the soft ravioli slides into my
mouth and I eat it now on God's earth
would you do that I think the fact that
someone gets pleasure out of it is what
makes it so much more sickening why
would you do that
Thanks I hate people now that's one
creepy pasta just the fact that he works
at the White House makes it worse
Thanks I hate gummy bear waffles that
looks delicious
Thanks I hate BuzzFeed I've always hated
thirsty but let's see what they say it's
finally time we talked about the hot dad
from inside out what is wrong with you
who has these thoughts I'm pretty sure
there are better examples of why you can
hate BuzzFeed but fine fine thanks I
hate BuzzFeed thanks I hate it oh my god
somebody thinks I wish I haven't seen
already why do I have to add more things
to the list I didn't want to know this
what am I even supposed to do with this
information you might think this is
insignificant but know this change is my
whole world view this changes my whole
approach to life it's
and why I live it hell why would you
feel sick I just feel awful why am I
doing this thanks I hate easy cups now
it's peanut butter haven't you all
realize that the master bowl is just a
poke ball with Wario's dong stretched
over we must continue we must fight on
once we're through with this we will be
immortal we can do this I hate chicken
I'm not watching that
I'm not Thanks I hate this my friend's
cat why am i laughing my friend cat eye
surgery now he has no pants this is like
Donald Duck isn't it
oh poor cat he said me there is that
kept pretty sexy says shamed awesome am
i right
/ brofist if you agree oh wait we
haven't hit 100 million thanks I hate
sneakers just imagine how far we'll be
in 20 years behold
- nickel
in the codsworth am i watching are they
fusing music oh god no why did someone
make this stop I don't see Thomas the
Tank Engine refuses I hate this video
okay oh my god that's the worst oh my
god hahaha
stop thinking okay I don't need you hit
don't rule your own cars Marie not cars
my favorite is a franchise cars do we
seriously a really good bill I can't
watch it anymore you've been sick
disgusting despicable person I'm done
I'm absolutely done tuber simulator it's
now so relevant that it's got a brand
new minigame cranium drop the crane and
get fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new pics
links and legs guys lake